thank you
[Music]
Ohio deputies responded to a situation
that was happening outside of a home
when a six-year-old boy was found
standing there with an open Smirnoff Ice
in his hand oh she's [ __ ] chilled
yeah he's chill as [ __ ] he's the chills
can I ever met
advice the police have responded to this
particular child many times the second
time many times the second time the same
child was later found riding a scooter
while also holding a Smirnoff Ice Dude
the Kid Likes what he likes he's [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ]
um so both times the authorities
approached the boy's mother and she both
times was like oh I didn't know he's he
stole one of my drinks again
however classic what's been going on
um they pulled the boy aside the the
authorities and they go what's up with
all the Smirnoffs right let's go why
don't you do Bud Light no no
um he says so he tells the police
officers I'm not kidding it either he
says
um a friend of his dad has been giving
him Smirnoffs regularly and they help
him sleep
oh [ __ ] the six-year-old boy they're
turning him into alcoholic a single
digit age
I got [ __ ] insomnia officer
you're gonna help me chill out yeah they
help me chill out you want one right
yeah it helps me sleep
so don't ask me which flavor okay
strawberry it's red white and blue yeah
it's seasonal but he gets it all year
round they have a case of it it's Ohio
huh Ohio yeah
um I Heard Ohio was quite the Trashy
State yep from who Joe but then um Drew
Carey he always made it kind of nice
Ohio 90s Ohio yeah true carry huh I've
only been to I've only been to Columbus
Ohio and that place sucks ass really
what sucks about it Columbus what is it
what would you compare it to I think if
you asked the Mayor of Columbus you'd be
like this place sucks
next question that's Drew Carey of Ohio
right Cleveland I don't know Cleveland
yeah it was so boring like there was so
little going on I could have laid in the
middle of the road and they're downtown
and I would not even worry about getting
run over oh that sounds so romantic
sounds like a good trade yeah dude that
place was dead I thought when I think of
Ohio I don't I forget those cities exist
I think of um Juggalos
oh like I just think of cornfield insane
Posse and I just think of pronounced
Gigolo jiggle no I feel I I think of
like white kids like in the trailer park
listening to Juggalos wow Dave Chappelle
makes it seem pretty chill where does he
live oh that's right he's in Ohio yeah
either Dayton or Cleveland but he's in
Ohio it seems like such a jet Setter I I
don't think he's ever tied down anywhere
so he lives there yeah he lives there he
like walks around the town he said he
said he nobody bothers you yeah he lives
in a small town that everyone knows of
him no one bothers him and he just loves
his little Community yeah Nikki said one
of the worst things she ever did with
with a celebrity was uh she was at a bar
and she was working there right and like
Dave Chappelle basically closed down the
bar and just like was giving everybody
drinks and so everyone's having a great
[ __ ] time right and then it's like
towards the end of the night and uh and
Nikki and she's been shooting the [ __ ]
with Dave Chappelle the whole [ __ ]
night everyone has right and then the
end of the night
um she's like hey just wanted to say
okay
I'm a big fan of your work and then he
like
like gave her the stink eye
and then left
and she's like that was the most [ __ ]
awkward thing ever but like apparently
it was like kind of what you guys are
talking about where it's like everybody
just kind of leaves them well no one
treats him like a person but then once I
think she raised his status oh [ __ ] out
and so she knows now what happened but
like back then she's like 20 [ __ ] two
[ __ ] that dude no no she was just like
confused really but but it was like I
thought we were having a good girl yeah
it was just like hey I just think you're
tight you know you can't Vibe on the
same level he just yeah he couldn't keep
it like he wanted to be just one of the
people I think see what she should have
said was like no no no it's not from
your stand-up it's from Robin Hood Men
in Tights like you're a chew thing that
was so sick but your other stuff I don't
[ __ ] like I don't like your stuff
yeah like the stuff you got right now
[ __ ] it and then he has to prove himself
my stand-up is good it's good you know
which is a very successful tactic I had
a Dave Chappelle moment at The Improv
where uh like after the show he he went
up you know the little guest spot but
when he does a guest spot I mean
everybody knows will be like there for
like hour two hours doing his thing
after
um people were taking pictures with like
the comic so it was I was like oh cool
I'm gonna get a pig ask for a pick
whatever he was he was talking but uh I
was trying to get his attention and I
feel like I was I was talking like too
low so I tried the second one I was like
uh Dave you [ __ ] and I guess I
got in my head or something but I ended
up saying it like kind of too loud oh
[ __ ] can I get a picture
and and he heard that one he was like he
was like he he had a reaction of like
yeah and then I was like dang it I don't
want it anymore oh he was just like yeah
come on like that I was like is he in
the picture like this yo we take the
picture and then when I when I when I
get up thank you man I think I'm all
like I got a picture I look at it like
it's blurry like it I don't know bro but
I was like damn it man like I was like I
yelled at Dave I yelled at him you know
when I was just like trying to get a
perfect octave so he could hear it but
now you got to post this photo yeah I
gotta post it I gotta post it when that
happens and you're like set to perform
like at a like when there's like six
comics about to go up and then Dave
shows up and then the place goes all
right Dave's just gonna take the rest of
time do you guys still get paid oh no I
don't I mean I haven't you don't even
get paid you don't really get paid out
here but either way like when Dave shows
up and you haven't performed yet and
you're on the lineup yeah I mean yeah
you just got bumped right enjoy the show
you don't say learn actually you know
what I'm saying like you know so nobody
ever looks at that as like a oh what the
[ __ ] some dude yeah some dude yeah yeah
they got some guy who's just on TV and
then he's kind of a hack but not not
necessarily Dave Chappelle right yeah no
Dave Chappelle it's cool but it's also a
thing where it's like you got your folks
who came out to see you you know I mean
your fans came up to see you like you
know your fans like yo thanks for
bringing us to see Dave dude yeah yeah I
guess that's understandable but if it's
like Carrot Top you got bummed in his
Carrot Top and it's like oh God damn and
then the club is down though because
it's Carrot Top still then you're like
well [ __ ] and you're like man this guy
said it's actually really good at one of
my first shows like I was bringing
everyone out and it was like 7 30 at the
comedy store and then uh By the time
because all these other people start
popping in by the time I got up it was
11 30. and the crowd way different
everyone's drunk heckling left and right
that's just normal [ __ ] yeah and if like
20 of your friends show up maybe only
three or four of them stay now and then
now they're just like oh oh they hate
everything they go up tonight and I'm
like trust me yeah they're all mad at
you yeah I hate you they hate the show
they hate the club forever and then
Byron Allen comes and everyone's got to
stop
dude because I went to a Byron Allen
Show and I and I was I know you know I
know you know you're [ __ ] lucky man I
suffered through Brian Allen Byron Allen
was you ever seen Commerce Unleashed
with Byron Allen uh the best show yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm familiar were he like
you know like he would have you here and
he's like so Chris tell me about what
happened with you getting stuck in a
bird cage it's crazy and then and you're
like well Byron so yeah I was um you
know I was looking for my bird I was
like wait I feed this bird every day I
just took my head in the cage you know
and then I got my head stuck in the bird
cage and then they cut the canned
audience laughing because nobody's
laughing because it's so [ __ ]
awkwardly presented because and I know
why I know nobody's laughing because I
was [ __ ] there in the audience when I
first moved to LA that was like one of
the first things I ever did was I got a
gig as an extra for Comics unleash Byron
Allen it was 12 hours of pure comedy
hell oh [ __ ] pirate Allen would like try
a joke out it doesn't work and then his
writer staff will come out and they'll
only cut and then they're all like
talking for way too long and then he
tries it again and like does a different
emphasis on the same word but the
audience is like he laughs again and
he's like I think we got that and then
it's like like that was the show TV show
would play it like at 1am yeah bro but
you know what you made Millions off of
it it was a syndication he's a [ __ ]
billionaire yeah who's laughing grandma
what they would do I was there right so
so they would have um a warm-up comic
did a warm comic come out
and then he was trying to warm us up but
like it's cold in there and everyone's
hungry and [ __ ] and that was at the
start so then
um they're like everybody give us a like
a big laugh and then there and then we
all have to fake laugh for the camera
and then they would just keep on cutting
that [ __ ] yeah and they would like have
to reverse image it I'm Different uh
different levels of labs a big one a
middle one a a clap one yeah but then
like those are the only times we ever
laughed was during the can laugh parts
so then you have a bunch of people in
the same clothes who are laughing at the
same octaves right and then they have to
reverse image it they have to like
change the brightness like [ __ ] like
change the colors of our shirts
to like make a guy's hair look different
and [ __ ] like just to make it look not
jarring when they keep cutting the same
[ __ ] laughs isn't that so cool about
you gave him in this studio audience
like of all people just [ __ ] slapped
at his knee oh bro it was like really
good research for your actual humor this
is these big breaks to actually be there
no it wasn't it was awful to be watching
it from your perspective oh my God
filter it's going through well yeah
learning learning how Comics pitched
their material was interesting yeah it
was very fascinating because that's
exactly what that show is it's just a
pitch right it's just a pitch and then a
pitch for you to do your start to do
your stand up which we we've done
Shameless material yeah it's so bad but
when you watch like he's just
alley-ooping himself every time no he's
out tell him about the birdcage thing oh
sure but it's so unnatural yeah it's
he's just really bad at hosting honestly
he's really bad McDonald would always
make fun of it and he would go he said
that in a real episode Byron Allen was
like so they tell me you're getting
older
it was that bad guys like old jokes dude
by the end of it the audience was so
sick of his hosting that he would say
something like that and everyone like oh
it was like that he's like I think we
got it no and the and the crew the
producers and the crew were just
constantly apologizing to us because we
had to keep staying it was it was crazy
by the way on top of all that wildly
successful but and he had all the best
Comics at the time they all wanted to be
on TV all the all the comics are carnies
right they just want to be on [ __ ] TV
so that they can go sell out a show
somewhere on tour and they can put it as
a credit Comics only that's it it's on
NBC and then that [ __ ] worked back then
especially you put that on your website
like oh I'm on CBS
it doesn't matter if I'm on at four in
the morning
[Music]
[Music]